this unassuming office building in
Arlington Virginia has a big secret it's
home to DARPA the world's most
successful and secretive research agency
people in this building are responsible
for funding the next generation of U.S
military technology but despite making
such important decisions and managing an
annual budget of more than three billion
dollars DARPA has only around 200
employees so how exactly does DARPA
deploy so much money and still stay
efficient most government agencies are
bloated with thousands of extra
employees but DARPA was able to
basically lay the foundation for the
entire modern internet with just one
million dollars The Story begins more
than 65 years ago on a day that changed
the course of human history
thank you
at 10 28 PM Moscow time on the 4th of
October 1957 the Soviet Union launched
the Sputnik satellite from scientific
research test range number five and
reached the first major Milestone of the
Space Race publicly America's leaders
did their best to remain calm but
privately they were reeling
until two days ago that sound had never
been heard on this Earth suddenly it has
become as much a part of 20th century
life as the aware of your vacuum cleaner
it's a report from man's farthest
Frontier the radio signal transmitted by
the Soviet Sputnik the first man-made
satellite as it passed over New York
earlier today across the country and
within the corridors of power there was
a fear that the Soviet Union had gained
a decisive upper hand in the Cold War
Sputnik was bad enough but our national
security officials understood that the
rocket that launched it into space could
potentially be used to carry much more
destructive payloads fear quickly
morphed into determination our leaders
promised that never again would the
United States be taken by surprise by an
adversary from the 6th of October 1957
until the end of that month the New York
Times published 279 pieces which
mentioned the satellite that's more than
11 articles every single day remember it
was less than 15 years since the end of
World War II with the destruction of
Nazi Germany and Imperial Japan
America's military and civilian leaders
were confident that the nation was on
the path to becoming the world's most
powerful country they knew the Soviet
Union was also in a strong position
after the war despite the massive number
of it had suffered but they were shocked
by the speed and size of the
technological leap that Sputnik
represented in a column published six
days after the launch one of America's
most respected commentators Walter
Lipman wrote that Sputnik showed that
America had become complacent Lipman was
searing in his analysis Russia was in
shambles after World War II but somehow
they were moving faster than America if
the United States wanted to prove that
capitalism was a better economic system
than communism they needed to respond
and quickly it wasn't just commentators
who were ringing the alarm Bell night
after night America's leaders told the
public that Sputnik meant that the
United States was under threat just
listen to what Sam Rayburn the Speaker
of the House of Representatives at the
time had to say about it people of the
United States have been humiliated
they're Disturbed and they're unhappy
Sputnik was a massive propaganda victory
for the Soviet Union and its leaders
less than half a century after being a
backwards country ruled by a
dysfunctional aristocracy the Soviet
Union had beaten the mighty Americans
into space and as if the first Sputnik
launch wasn't worrying enough just over
one month later the Soviets launched a
second satellite weighing over 1 100
pounds Sputnik 2 was much larger than
its predecessor and it proved
definitively that the rocket used to
launch the Sputnik probes into space
could also be used to launch
intercontinental ballistic missiles
despite the seemingly obvious threat
President Eisenhower initially played it
cool when reporters asked him for his
thoughts about the launch he said it
didn't raise his apprehensions not one
iota why was the U.S president a man who
had been America's greatest Soldier so
calm about the Soviet Union launching
the world's first satellite the answer
is actually pretty simple America's
intelligence and military leaders knew
that it was coming according to recently
Declassified documents the CIA had
forecast that Moscow planned to put a
satellite into orbit before the end of
the year one intelligence officer even
predicted the exact launch date and was
only off by two weeks Eisenhower was
being honest when he said he wasn't
surprised or worried but the fact is
millions of Americans were and they
couldn't understand the president's
reaction
what do you think about America not
being able to do with that
as a military
it's on a job like
football show
badly
Eisenhower realized that he needed to
respond even if the response was mostly
just about PR luckily a response was
already in the works in an effort to
encourage scientific collaboration
between nations a group of scientists
and diplomats organized a global
scientific collaboration called the
international geophysical year it
brought together 67 countries including
the U.S and the Soviet Union and
Eisenhower's press secretary months
before the project kicked off had
publicly announced that the U.S intended
to launch small Earth circling
satellites so even while Sputnik was
circling the planet and invading the
headlines the U.S Navy was hard at work
just two months after the Sputnik launch
the Vanguard TV3 stood on the launch pad
at Cape Canaveral it hadn't been easy
even on the day of the launch technical
problems kept pushing back the countdown
journalists from Washington DC joked
that the Vanguard was like a civil
servant because it won't work and you
can't fire it but at 11 30 local time
the countdown reached zero first stage
booster ignited and the rocket shot off
the launch pad everything went fine for
about two seconds then the engines cut
out and in front of millions of
Americans watching on live television
the Vanguard TV3 fell back onto the pad
and exploded into a giant Fireball the
Vanguard wasn't a civil servant anymore
now headlines called it names like
flopnik kaputnik oopsnik and stay put
Nick a second launch on the 5th of
February 1958 failed less than a minute
after it launched for the Navy which had
been asked directly by the president to
design the Vanguard rocket it was a
disaster but for the Army it was an
opportunity a week after the Soviets
launched the follow-up to Sputnik the
U.S Secretary of Defense directed The
Army to launch a satellite of its own
the end product Explorer 1 became
America's first ever successful
satellite launch when it entered Orbit
on February 1st 1958. it was smaller
than Sputnik but its launch sent it
deeper into space the Soviet Union may
have made the first move but the U.S was
now firmly in the Space Race the
Eisenhower administration had other
tricks of its sleeve too around the same
time as the Vanguard TV3 was exploding
on the launch pad the U.S Secretary of
Defense Neil McElroy had a meeting with
two Veterans of the Manhattan Project
one of the men who met with mcalroy was
a nuclear physicist named Ernest
Lawrence Lawrence was so brilliant that
he won the Nobel Prize when he was just
38 years old by the time he met with the
secretary Lawrence was advocating
extensively for government sponsorship
of large scientific programs the other
man who met with McElroy was Charles
Thomas his post-government career took
him in a different direction he was the
president of Monsanto in their meeting
these two men invoked the inspiring
example of the Manhattan Project to try
and persuade McElroy that the U.S
government should create a new agency to
lead the country's space research
McElroy promised that he would consider
the idea after two weeks of operation
McElroy returned to face Congress he and
Eisenhower had made their decision the
United States government would create an
agency to consolidate the pentagon's
missile technology and space programs
what would go on to become the world's
most successful military research agency
was born not with fireworks but with a
two-page memo on February 7 1958. it was
called the advanced research projects
agency or arpa and just as a quick note
arpa would eventually be renamed to
DARPA the defense Advanced research
projects agency So to avoid confusion
I'm just going to call it DARPA from
here on out the new agency needed people
to run it after Consulting with his
peers outside of government McElroy
settled on Roy Johnson a charismatic
vice president at General Electric as
darpa's inaugural director in what would
have been a highly controversial Choice
McElroy briefly considered choosing the
German rocket scientist Warner Von Braun
to be the first Chief scientist in
instead he settled on the young
physicist Herbert York York was still a
young man he wasn't even 40 yet but he'd
worked at the Oak Ridge laboratory the
place where the uranium was enriched for
the little boy bomb which was dropped on
Hiroshima after that he was put in
charge of recruiting scientists to
design the first thermonuclear weapons
following the national crisis of
confidence brought on by the launch of
Sputnik the United States had responded
by launching a satellite into orbit and
creating a military research agency
quickly DARPA had its two most important
Personnel in place which made it all the
more surprising that less than two years
later the initiative was already on
death's door when NASA was created in
July of 1958 it assumed responsibility
for America's civilian space research
but everyone thought that DARPA would
hold on to the military space programs
the Armed Forces had another idea though
they sensed weakness and they started a
bureaucratic War inside the Pentagon to
get their space space programs back it
didn't help that darpa's head scientist
Herbert York had left the organization
and was now working at the Pentagon Roy
Johnson who is running DARPA at the time
was desperately trying to keep the
organization relevant but he didn't have
many supporters left the Press was
starting to promote the idea that
military space projects were the
exclusive domain of the Pentagon not
DARPA and so when the New York Times
published an article calling Herbert
York the top space official in the U.S
government Roy Johnson was Furious he
wrote to the Secretary of Defense
demanding clarification and included a
copy of the article on which he
physically wrote that the deputy
secretary had promised him that DARPA
would be responsible for all space
matters there was just one problem with
his argument the deputy secretary that
Johnson was citing had been dead for
almost three weeks Johnson and York had
never seen eye to eye one was a
businessman appointed to run a tight
ship the other was a scientist with his
head in the clouds and now York had the
upper hand by the end of the year York
had successfully transferred America's
military space programs back to the
armed forces and just like that darpa's
main reason for existing didn't exist
anymore the question now was why even
keep DARPA around at all it had just
lost the battle inside of the Pentagon
it didn't have its own offices or any
permanent employees there were calls for
it to be folded into the Pentagon even
abolished the future looked Bleak but an
unlikely hero was about to emerge
William godell was a very unusual choice
to serve as darpa's next deputy director
he'd been hand-picked to represent the
intelligence Community he wasn't a
scientist he didn't work in a lab or at
a desk he'd even care that much about
futuristic technology he actually
believe that the space race was mostly a
sideshow godell had been hand-picked to
represent the intelligence community and
while most Pentagon officials were
focusing on Soviet nuclear and
conventional forces godell believed that
the bigger threat to American interests
was in small-scale Insurgent conflicts
in places like southeast Asia and the
Middle East to learn more Godel went on
a fact-finding mission across southeast
Asia he was looking for answers to two
key questions why were the Communists
gaining a foothold and what could the
United States do about it at the time
America's intelligence and military
leaders believed in the Domino Theory
which argued that communism in one
country would quickly spread to its
neighbors godell believed that DARPA
could help The Dominoes stay upright his
plan was to undermine communist
influence in Southeast Asia all without
the use of any U.S soldiers instead of
relying on massive numbers of ground
troops godell would focus on developing
new technologies a month after godell
returned home he helped create project
agile and with a stroke of a pen DARPA
had a new guiding principle
counter-insurgency Bill godell wanted to
use project agile to create a global
database of people and places that the
United States could draw on whenever it
needed once it had enough training data
it could be used to provide policy
makers with specific recommendations
that best suited the Tactical situation
godell was especially interested in
South Vietnam the conflict wasn't on the
radar of most Americans yet but it was
flashing bright red on his godell could
see that the Communist Insurgency was
gaining strength so he searched for a
way to undermine the Soviets and prop up
an American Ally plus he figured
stopping the Insurgency would put DARPA
in the pentagon's good graces godell's
basic pitch was if we can't fight
Communists in space why not fight them
in the jungle in June of 1961 he set off
on a top-secret mission to Saigon with
eighteen thousand dollars in cash in his
briefcase I know it sounds like
something ripped directly from a spy
movie but godell was serious that
eighteen thousand dollars was a down
payment for a U.S funded combat
development and test center the idea was
that this new Saigon Outpost would be a
research Hub to develop technology for
the South Vietnamese counter-insurgency
effort it was an example of darpa's
founding philosophy the development of
military technology that enabled the US
and its allies to surprise its enemies
project agile had an important Ally the
new president John F Kennedy Kennedy was
an Ardent cold warrior during the
election campaign he repeatedly claimed
that the Soviet Union's missile
stockpile was an imminent threat to the
United States and this was a really
smart campaign move even though Kennedy
kept saying that the U.S had way fewer
missiles than the Soviet Union that
wasn't actually true but his opponent
Eisenhower couldn't call him out on it
because details about the missile
program were classified Kennedy's plan
worked and America elected him president
DARPA also got a new director with a PhD
in electrical engineering Jack Karina
was every bit the scientist that bill
godell was not the two men represented
opposite sides of the debate that had
been raging ever since DARPA was created
was it a National Security Agency where
the scientists followed orders or was it
a science agency that also served
National Security godell the former spy
believed it was all about National
Security ruina the persistent scientist
believed it was more of a science agency
the debate didn't get resolved in the
jungles of Vietnam and unfortunately it
would soon be overshadowed by a
harrowing sequence of events first was
JFK's assassination Kennedy's death
meant that darpa's staff didn't just
lose a leader they also lost a staunch
Ally who happened to sit atop the U.S
government second was godell's
indictment on fraud charges and third of
course was the United States being
dragged into the Quagmire of Vietnam
what started as Bill godell's dream of
defeating the North Vietnamese without
sending any American troops in became a
nightmare judged by these metrics
project agile was a failure it failed to
stop the Insurgency from escalating into
full-blown War it failed to prevent the
commitment of U.S soldiers and it failed
to save South Vietnam project agile was
canceled in 1974 when Bill godell was
asked to list his successes he gave a
one-word answer none I actually disagree
project agile was a failure but it still
marked a turning point in the history of
DARPA because following the loss of its
space projects DARPA seemed destined to
Fade Into Obscurity Vietnam rescued it
and elevated it to the status of
Pentagon Insider we'll never know the
full story but it's possible that the
legendary innovations that DARPA would
go on to be associated with such as
stealth aircraft GPS and drones could
only happen because of the role played
by men like Bill Goodell in Vietnam
let's leave Vietnam and go to another
theater of the Cold War Cuba you
remember the Cuban Missile Crisis it was
a genuinely terrifying standoff for 13
days the world held its breath until the
Soviets finally agreed to remove their
nuclear missiles from Cuba on the
condition that America removed their own
missiles from Italy and turkey it was
the closest that the Cold War ever came
to a full-scale nuclear war today the
Cuban Missile Crisis is remembered as a
massive humiliation and loss of prestige
for the Soviets its very own Sputnik
moment but its Legacy is actually much
more important once the relief in
Euphoria had subsided leaders at the
Pentagon conducted a post-mortem
analysis of those 13 days their analysis
LED them to the realization that one of
the reasons the situation almost
spiraled tragically out of control was
because they couldn't communicate
effectively in real time with either
their own forces or with Soviets the
risk that the Pentagon had identified
was a subset of the command and control
problem basically this refer refers to
how designated commanding officers
exercise authority over their forces
accurate and timely communication is
clearly an important part of this
equation but it had become clear that
despite the huge technological advances
that had been made in Weaponry like
nuclear weapons icbms and advanced
bombers Communications technology just
hadn't progressed at the same rate and
in a world with nuclear weapons a single
action taken on the basis of wrong or
outdated information could spell the end
of the world it's easy to see how this
was a problem that kept people at the
Pentagon up at night thankfully it was
the kind of problem DARPA excelled at
solving and although the pentagon's
leaders didn't know it yet the most
important piece of the puzzle had just
entered the building this puzzle piece
went by the name of Joseph Carl
Robinette licklider or lick to his
friends his history with DARPA began
when he received a letter from a man
named Charles Bray Bray wasn't actually
a DARPA staff member instead he wrote
wrote to lick lighter in his capacity as
a member of a research group that had
been directed by the Pentagon to look
into using psychology for National
defense purposes that might sound pretty
weird but remember hysteria about
brainwashing was at its peak The
Manchurian Candidate a book about a
returned pow who gets converted into a
deep cover Soviet spy had just gripped
the nation DARPA and the Pentagon
already had experience using insights
from physics and chemistry to develop
new military Technologies they thought
psychology might hold valuable knowledge
that could help American forces gain an
edge on the battlefield Bray had a hunch
he believed that the pentagon's
commanded control issue and the
application of psychology to Warfare had
more in common than people realized
after all he reasoned both were
ultimately about communication and in
Joseph lichlider Bray thought he had
just the guy to help him turn a hunch
into an actual project licklider was a
psychologist with a keen interest in the
new field of computing shortly before he
received the offer to join DARPA
lichlider had published an influential
paper titled online man computer
simulation the paper describes many of
The Logical components of modern
Computing but lick lighter didn't stop
there he also predicted that man
computer symbiosis would be essential
for military officials who wanted to
leverage computers but not completely
delegate decision making lick lighter
would quickly build on that work within
six months of joining DARPA he wrote a
memo that is regarded as one of the most
significant intellectual milestones in
what eventually became the internet he
addressed it to the intergalactic
computer network this was partly a nerdy
joke and partly a clever reference to
how DARPA operated remember how DARPA
has just over 200 employees well they
achieved so much with such a small head
count because they bring together teams
of experts from different sectors to
work on specific project this this means
they can work efficiently only spend
what they need to and disband the team
when the project is over to work on the
intergalactic computer network lick
lighter brought together a team of
scientists researchers and even people
from the business World it didn't matter
where they were from they shared a
single purpose lick lighter's memo to
them began by asking one important
question how do you get communication
started among totally disconnected
groups licklighter went on to sketch the
solution that was coming together in his
head he covered Concepts that are
commonplace in software engineering
today things like metadata natural
language processing compilers and
debugging he explained that he wanted
the intergalactic computer network to be
capable of writing programs storing
photos and facilitating communication
it's amazing to read something where a
person is trying to tie together a bunch
of threads in a way that no one ever has
before remember lick lighter was part of
an agency inside of the Department of
Defense at the height of the Cold War he
may have been a scientist but he under
stood his grief this new network had to
deliver a ton of features by the
standards of the 1960s it had to be fast
it had to be secure and it had to
withstand nuclear war flicklighter laid
out an incredible vision for what would
basically become the modern internet
decades later and he did it while only
working at DARPA for two years but he
certainly made the most out of his time
there not only did he build out a plan
for a military internet but he even
explained to his colleagues how
civilians would use computer networks in
the future as well in one presentation
at the Marriott Hotel in Washington DC
lichlider explained to his co-workers
how in the future people could have a
console in their kitchens which they
would use to find recipes this was 60
years ago people didn't have Alexa's
they didn't have Wi-Fi they didn't even
have clunky personal computers yet all
of that was years away but this guy
could clearly see the future he
understood that most of the technology
required to realize his vision was years
away but he also knew that securing
buy-in from his colleague superiors was
a vital ingredient of success The
Intergalactic computer network team
continued to meet even after his
departure in 1965 lick lighter handed
over the project to a man named Bob
Taylor now Taylor wanted to create a
network that would span America so he
went to his boss DARPA director Charles
herzfeld this guy was a huge fan of lick
lighter and had been obsessed with
computers since he was a young man
getting a cross-country internet Network
off the ground wouldn't be easy they
need to build new technology they need
to Wrangle different government
organizations and they definitely need
money today ambitious projects like that
often require multiple lengthy Grant
applications but here's how Bob Taylor
applied for the funding to build the
network he just knocked on his boss's
door herzfeld asked how much money he
needed to get the work off the ground
Taylor thought for a moment and then
answered a million dollars or so
herzfeld thought for a moment and then
gave his answer you got it and that was
it it was money well spent the new
network was now called arpanet and the
first host to host connection was
established at 10 30 pm on October 29
1969. by December a four node network
was up and running Ray Tomlinson a
member of The Intergalactic Network used
the arpanet to send himself the world's
first email in 1971. by 1973 the people
using the network started to refer to it
as the internet to two decades later the
project had run its course and was ready
to be handed over to the private sector
arpanet was formally decommissioned in
1990 and tech companies have been
aggressively growing the internet ever
since this was a perfect demonstration
of DARPA at its best after overseeing
the technology from its Inception to its
proof of concept it pushed it out into
the world where it transformed the way
we live our lives in order to understand
how private technology companies have
capitalized on the growth of the
internet you have to watch my video on
the complete history of Silicon Valley
next thanks for watching